and
we started today talking about
afghanistan it's best we in that way as
well
megan mccain
megan mccain re-emerged this past
weekend she's no longer on the view so
she's got to turn to twitter to get her
idiotic ideas out there to the world so
she goes on twitter
this past weekend condemns
all of these people saying we should get
out of afghanistan including the
biden administration saying this here's
her tweet
democrats like to wax poetic a lot about
what my dad would have done and said
most of the time reinventing some weird
fantasy of who he was
let me tell you one damn thing
he would be raging in public and a
president biden about his this af
withdrawal in afghanistan raging
you know megan you don't really need to
tell us that
for two reasons first of all nobody
asked
i'm just gonna throw that out there
first literally nobody asked
and do you know why because that's my
second reason you don't need to tell us
this because
nobody cares
i'm sorry i don't care if you think that
john mccain was a hero if you think he
was a saint or if you think he was just
a
another conservative war hawk which he
was um
i don't care
what the man would have thought
about the withdrawal of troops from
afghanistan do you know why i don't care
because he's he's not a us senator
anymore he's
he's not even alive
so whether he supported it
or was against it please somebody
explain to me how that is relevant to
anything on this planet
honestly it's kind of the same argument
that republicans oh well what would the
founding father thing who cares
who cares is the answer to that question
who cares what the founders would have
thought
oh the same people that thought a black
slave only counted as three-fifths of a
human being yeah i don't care what their
opinion would be of today's current
political climate
oh john mccain is not happy
that we're pulling troops out of
afghanistan yeah thanks for reminding us
that the man never met an international
conflict that he didn't immediately fall
in love with
that's what megan mccain was really
doing there and this is why folks it
really is so dangerous
when democrats prop up these individuals
you know we've seen it with liz cheney
we saw it with john mccain just because
they hate the same person we didn't like
donald trump that doesn't mean they're
our friends that doesn't even mean
they're our allies
john mccain when he was still in the
senate still voted with republicans
was it 90 percent of the time liz
cheney's over 90 of the time
these people are not our friends they
are not our allies just because we
dislike the same person the enemy of my
enemy is not always my friend and we
have to get that through our heads and
thank you megan mccain for taking the
time over the weekend to remind us
that at the end of the day
your father god rest his soul
was just another republican
who wanted the u.s to be involved in as
many international conflicts as humanly
possible
i want to thank david and the entire
staff at the and david pakman show for
being so welcoming to me here i will be
with you once again tomorrow and until
then if for some reason you want any
more of me you can find me on youtube at
youtube.com
farronbalanced youtube.com the ring of
fire twitter facebook and instagram at
balanced stay tuned for today's bonus
show for the members we've got some
really great stories coming up i am
faring cousins in for david pakman
thanks for watching